Rob I remember we used to go to your
house and sit around literally at
Chuck's feet and he would just talk and
he would philosophize like like the Mark
Twain of animation and he had so many
interesting views of em that you
remember some of those conversations
some of the things that he talked about
Chuck you know had something I think to
say about everything the thing that was
amazing to me really about Chuck was
that she played such an important role
in keeping animation alive as some of
you might remember thirty years ago when
we got in to animation there was really
some question about whether it was gonna
stick around you know I think that there
was a chance or really a moment in time
where it really felt like there wouldn't
be any animation and looking around
today it's hard to imagine that that was
possible because animation has become
just so pervasive there's just so much
of it and Chuck at the time I think did
a lot not only with us but with
everybody that he met to really instill
in us a kind of an appreciation and not
just of animation but it but of life too
and you know that's I remember different
times we would go visit the different
studios and and you know people would
kind of look at the eyes so you want to
give him a business huh and that was
Anna Barbera and and you know they were
kind of discouraging and even though the
state of animation wasn't great Chuck
couldn't have been anything but
encouraging you know he wanted to bring
he want us to bring in our character
designs from our freshman year which I
was horrified of doing because again I
can't really draw but you put him down
and you go over them and say oh this is
a look at this thing you have going on
here that's pretty neat when we actually
had scenes to show he said bring your
scene down and and over our scenes I
remember having a break through there
it's like oh you can actually be that
extreme between two drawings when chuck
used to come to Cal oh I remember for
producer show he would just come in
sometime and I you know you just
couldn't believe he was coming then he
would say to me okay Jeff let's go take
a look your storyboard you know and it
pitched me your shoes pitch me your
stupid film you know so we take them
down
a 113 and he'd sit there in the chair
and we'd be pitching I'd be putting my
my student film to him and doing a gag
session with Chuck Jones I'd be like
holy cow it's like you know what's up
with this picture you know what I mean
when in lil and lo and behold years
later you know it just all comes around
and it was just an incredible time I
think to be sitting here right now 30
years later doing a panel discussion
about this is a very surreal thing I
mean just picture yourself being 20
years old and meeting this giant in the
industry that you'd grown up with and
all these years later being able to talk
about it here on this stage where you
where we met him basically one of the
things I remember about Chuck in terms
of philosophy is I remember we we were
showing him our drawings and somewhere
in one of our sketchbooks
someone had drawn a page of just
cartoony fish and chuck look at that he
goes okay he just said well you know
this is pointless
you can't caricature a fish because
you're just drawing another fish and it
was things like that we were like wow
he's right somewhere out there there's a
fish that looks like this so but that's
the way he thought and it made it made
us think that way I mean I think my
favorite piece of Chuck Jones advice was
when you're dealing with comedy and you
get something that makes you laugh and a
board and everything you know people try
to analyze what did i do right and chuck
always said humor is like a frog you can
dissect it it intends to die on you
you